[Music]
well i have a story of a very
loving dedicated mother yes who that is
so this 51 year old ukrainian woman oh
she spent three weeks
digging a 35 foot
long tunnel wow uh
and she and the depth about 10 feet or
they're saying that's a big
hole that's a deep why and so
the reason is because she was trying to
dig this hole and break into a prison
oh have her son escape that is the best
mom in the whole entire world
my mom would have sold me out like a
[ __ ] my mom would have said i deserved
it
alone and with like really basic
basic tools too what her hands look like
ten feet
deep with the whole look oh damn so she
ended up renting an airbnb
right by the prison wow she would stay
indoors the entire day like throughout
the day and then she will come out at
night and only work at night
and she did that so neighbors wouldn't
recognize her or anything so after she
was caught
neighbors were like yeah we literally
have never seen this woman so that part
of she's probably in love with her son
and her son's her boyfriend too
oh that's weird why don't you make it
weird guys that's weird oh sorry guys
made it really weird
that's so weird dude why don't i do that
so yeah so this is the prison and
this is a mother that's a badass mom
what's up with the it's underscore zp is
that her instagram handle
no it's the prison i don't know it's a
watermark
but yeah this is this is the tunnel
who's that lady reporter
she's a reporter just showing like
that's a ukrainian fbi ratting her ass
out
yeah and then these were the tools she
used that's all she used
yeah like that just shows
the mother's love is so strong kind of
mother's love though
see oh my god romantic life
you know what's funny i always say like
women can do
all of the jobs that are like cops and
robbers and all that [ __ ] but they're
not
motivated those two jobs
they're not motivated correctly i'm
saying that they they would be the
majority
so right now it's a male dominated sport
right
like cops and robbers right i'm not
saying that there
aren't good lady cops and good lady
robbers they exist
you're saying i'm just saying that
statistically there's more
males and i think the only reason why is
because
of what is motivating them if you tell
any woman to detectivize something
because of their kid
or their husband's gun or their they
think their husband's cheating or
whatever right
they will find that mother they'll be
relentless they'll do a better job than
the cia and fbi but that's why yeah you
can't hire a private eye
chick if she's not personally invested
is what you're saying yeah
she has to have it has to be her husband
it has to be something that is
properly motivated like if you tell them
a million dollars to like
oh maybe maybe they could be
money-hungry
women that are just like hey it is my
career i'm doing it but we'll session
but will she destroy at it is what joe's
saying mm-hmm
see if you hire and i'm talking about
majority right so there's always going
to be greedy
people male and female gold diggers
there's going to be people that are
money motivated but i'm saying like what
motivates like what is the what is the
manchurian candidate in all women
what is that thing that you go bam and
then they all of a sudden become
sherlock holmes we want to prove
you're wrong always okay if they're
motivated like that yep
we always and you guys can be cops and
robbers yeah
because i bet you can't rob that bank
oh yeah oh yeah [ __ ] watch i'm
gonna do it [ __ ]
and i'm gonna divorce your that's true
that's like amelia earhart right man
girls can't fly [ __ ] you crazy
oh really [ __ ] i'mma fly and get
lost
see your face again it's a sad story she
did it on purpose
peace [ __ ] i went to a different port
on [ __ ] in the bermuda triangle
yup cause i don't like your [ __ ]
night i just hope that somebody hears
what you just said
and then they respond with uh actually
joe this is agatha blah blah blah she's
one of the greatest private detectives
of all times like
whatever that's true because i believe
like uh carmen san diego
is a good ass spy because you could
never find that [ __ ] for how many
seasons
whatever right i lost the show dude i
get it
they exist all i'm saying is women have
a superpower
that if you can ignite it that [ __ ]
[ __ ] go
unstoppable so what's what superpower is
it that we can make
humans what's that is that not a
superpower huh not because everyone
always all women do it yeah
no not all women well true some are
barren that's true and they can't do it
yeah that's a superpower too though it
could be the men too
it's not that special if everyone does
it right it's like
it's only special if it's like this mom
this old hag has the energy to dig a
tunnel
that [ __ ] big she did cartel work
the [ __ ] the los zetas are looking at
this [ __ ] and they're like dude that
[ __ ] took us
she wrote three tons of dirt by herself
how long three weeks
three weeks the drug cartels are looking
at this like it took 50 men
to do what one mom was able to do look
at each other going like what were you
really doing this whole time right
come on this [ __ ] two weeks yeah
that's what i'm saying man that's a
superpower
you think you're like she was trying to
dig the whole and like she knew
like the prison cell location and
everything or was it just like on the
other side of the wall
yeah what if the what if the sun was on
this side of the prison and she was
digging it
she's like [ __ ] that's funny no i mean
she seems like she was very very
calculated
very like precise with her movements
and so i'm pretty sure she was how did
she get caught did she dig up
we don't know it says it's unclear how
she eventually got caught but she did
she she tunneled through the warden's
office she calculated the wrong one
oh [ __ ] all the ground's just rising
underneath his feet like mommy's
oh no she got pretty close though before
getting caught
so i'm like damn that's pretty crazy she
did a lot
she still didn't he's another feeling
but she failed let's talk about
how crazy is that to dig a hole like
that that's like every
seven-year-old's dream you try to reach
china with that [ __ ] right yeah
you want like a little cave that you can
have his little hideout and as you dig
it
like when you're like 10 feet down you'd
be scared that that
might crumble on you yeah that's scary
what if she didn't even think of all
that and she's like [ __ ] just my son i
gotta get my son out
because when you guys were getting your
pool built not gonna lie my
seven-year-old self looked at that and
said
damn i wish i [ __ ] dug that [ __ ] when
i saw it with the
the what do you call it the pavement on
it i was like man be so little
skateboard on that
oh yeah you know oh yeah should have
called it well i
when i was a kid i would think that now
i'm like i don't want to skateboard i'll
[ __ ] break my leg
really not you i know i know not you you
were skateboarding just last week here i
know but
i think i should think like that true
have you ever gone downstream that steep
with the skateboard yeah i think well
the steepest was a half pipe
that should look steep those are steep
it's scary that's scary as [ __ ] man be
on a skateboard and a half pipe ugh
my my brother got mad at me because i
didn't launch
um because his friend had a half pipe in
the backyard
and he's like man i brought you over
here and you didn't [ __ ] do this
oh that's a mean friend mom my brother
oh brother oh yeah and then i'm like
[ __ ] now i have to do this [ __ ] yeah you
ain't nobody fans were like barbecuing
some me they're like yeah if you don't
do it we're not gonna give you any meat
and i'm like [ __ ]
all right so then i went down and that
was the scariest [ __ ]
ever i just went down i went up and then
i just failed
oh oh she's slid back down yeah you just
you go
dude you're when you go down you just i
don't know if i could do it again yeah
you can't lean back
once you go down and you have to commit
and your body feels like
it's literally going straight but before
you know it you go back
up and then the scary part is going back
up too so i just bailed and i just said
i
did it i love watching the people at
venice
those skateboards they make you look so
just stand there for like an hour or a
couple hours just watching but have you
seen the [ __ ] razor blade scooter
people
those guys are [ __ ] crazy razor blade
scooter yeah
they'll like they go up and then they'll
spin it around them and it's kind of
funny
sorry if you do it the healy's people
though the what the heelys people
need they didn't [ __ ] did you ever own
any heelys because don't knock it
they're so fun well i saw a guy healing
across the street the other day and i
was just like come
on bro i've never seen a skilly at a
skate park
i never seen a healy at a skatepark
don't they get beat up before they get
in they do
i don't think they'll be allowed but you
know the other day i saw a roller skates
girl
they're they're very popular now yeah
but
on this on the skate park yeah that's
very popular because i've seen
inline skating where because i did that
i've never seen
roller skating where you do these
[ __ ] they'll like hold on to the edge
and then they like their feet are up in
the air and then they come back down
backwards and [ __ ]
are they roller skating or blading
skating
it's not going backwards that's like
going to a dirt bike park with a horse
yep right you're going backwards in time
and like i'm gonna [ __ ] bmx this
horse and [ __ ] now imagine when you land
all those tricks with the [ __ ] horse
you're gonna be like
boom so you you yeah with the
and they do the superman yeah yeah so
you literally grab onto the horse's mane
and you [ __ ] yourself from the horse
yeah if you can do it you're bad you
guys are pretty crazy you're back you're
doing a bear pack too
that just sounds like uh amish extreme
sports dude they have the carriage and
[ __ ] the amish game yeah
they got like haystacks and then they
drift that'll be so cool
i'm down i want to watch they should do
a show like that old-fashioned [ __ ] like
you
nascar but with chariots now and horse
that just sounds like an egyptian
movie like did they do they say like
spark like spartacus or i don't know
like a
roman one yeah they make one of those
every couple years yeah well i mean
that's in the movies though but to have
actual people that would be kind of sick
chariot races the closest to that is the
red bull right
like they're the where they make their
own soap car
soapbox oh yeah i want to see where they
have spikes on their [ __ ] wooden
wheels
and then they try to carve each other
out with that little rascals
but what's with that it's like the the
spike to a wooden wheel it doesn't
it doesn't deflate the tire it trips
them up because then when it's like
it crashes oh it cracks the spokes
and then they're gonna get stuck and
they're going to fly out i want to see a
chariot race i think that's
let's make it happen yeah that'd be
really cool in my cartoon brain you hit
the you hit the wood with the spike
thing and then the wood deflates
you got to blow the wood back up don't
worry get the pump out
do you guys feel like with age you are
more
cautious with certain things all the
time so what i
like going back into like skateboarding
and extreme sports and things like that
what i'm starting to see is i'm learning
much
faster but i don't take stupid risks
so like i will before i would just be
like that's a hill
[ __ ] it like where i would i wouldn't do
that anymore i'll be like all right
what is the way to stop okay you do left
break first
and then let me practice learn first not
just like dive and head first
i never i would skate without knowing
how to skate
like i would be like oh i don't know how
to skateboard but i could stand
so here's a hill let me just do it for
me it's like yes
it's like i learn slower and faster
because you know a lot of the extreme
sports stuff
it requires full commitment to do it
right like a backflip you can't half
back
no you can't step a back foot and same
thing with like jumps
it's either you really get air and
understand how that weightlessness feels
or you kind of just go and you just kind
of go over you'd never really jump it
you just kind of ride over it
so there's a part of me where i'm older
and i'm scared of that feeling now
so it takes me like more baby steps to
slowly get there but then
i never really just do it whereas before
i was a kid
i would just do it and have that moment
of weightlessness and maybe i'll crash
two or three times
but since i actually felt that and i can
control the air i'm like cool i got it
now
but now i don't have the full commitment
i'm just like i just kind of baby
stepping in i don't know
maybe you get tired maybe i don't want
to learn this that bad anyways
i'm glad though because when i was a kid
you feel like you can do anything
sometimes especially if you watch like a
peter pan movie or something you're like
i can [ __ ] fly
and then you start jumping off the couch
like 30 times in a row i've made some
regrets that way
you know what i'm saying like and
nowadays i'm like i can't fly i could
barely [ __ ] move around
i'm like that and then i just drink a
little bit and i'm like alright let's
[ __ ] go
i can fly no i'm way more scared than i
was a kid
[Music]
[Music]